this is
ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
christy wright best-selling author of my
new devotional living true 40 days to
get back to you i'm also a ramsay
personality
and i'm joined today by my good friend
also best-selling author
also ramsay personality anthony o'neal
they let us do this again together this
is gonna be fun
it's gonna be real fun you know it may
not be as fun as last time but it'll be
it may be better here's one of the
things people can count on
if you and i are hosting the show listen
they're going to get fired up
yeah like we don't coast we don't even
have a gear no that is coasting
no cruise control we go all in and we
are here for you so we're taking your
calls today triple eight eight two five
five if you have a question about money
if you have a question about business
maybe it's a side business small
business home-based business or just
you got an idea and you're not sure if
it can be a business
or maybe you just have some questions
about life
and you need some advice we are here
for you phones are open triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you know anthony i was
thinking about this idea of advice this
is what we do you do this on your show
with the table yep i do this with the
chrissy wright show these come out
weekly
you guys can find us on youtube or
wherever you listen to podcasts on
instagram all that good stuff we love to
help people
yeah and we love to give them advice and
give them hope and and give them
direction where we can
um just yesterday i had a conversation
with someone that is an expert in the
parenting space
okay it was 50 minutes okay and anthony
i walked out of that conversation
literally lighter oh wow like just
simple advice from someone that is an
expert with
boys and the ages that my boys are i'd
had so much
angst about how do we handle this
situation or that situation and i and i
was like you know what i need help with
this
i need to ask someone else and so i had
a great conversation with someone
author um brilliant parenting expert and
anthony when i left i just
literally felt lighter that's what
advice
and help from someone else can do it
sets you free
it really does and for me when you get
practical and
good wisdom um in whatever situation
you're in
wisdom and knowledge uh you feel better
you
feel equipped to go back into your
particular space and as long as you
apply
check this out the advice the wisdom
the knowledge then you will do better
but now
uh if you don't apply the advice the
wisdom and the knowledge to your
situation to your life
then what then you just wasted your time
yeah and it's interesting because i feel
like that there are certain things in
life
that we just expect ourselves to know
how to do
so like uh let me give you an example
let me go back to high school i remember
i joined the track team in high
school and i was fast but i wasn't
uh trained and so i had this coach that
was that trained me
in running now you just think you're
supposed to know how to run right like
everybody knows how to run you just
you just you just do it no christie
you would have talked about this before
were you really fast
i was only white girl the track team
was the only white girl on the four by
100 relay team i think that's fast
a little over to high school yeah anyway
here's the thing though but i had a
coach that trained us in
drills and sprints and weightlifting and
all the things that you do
to get faster to get stronger and as a
result i performed better but running is
one of those things that you think i'm
just supposed to know how to do it
parenting i think is one of those things
you're supposed to just know how to do
it money is one of those things i'm just
supposed to know how to do it
no and and we don't we don't if
especially if our parents don't teach us
especially if we don't learn it in
school
we're fumbling around in the dark we're
living paycheck to paycheck
we're frustrated with our kids and don't
know why we can't see eye to eye and
help them and
and we're going hey guys listen the one
thing you need is what anyone needs
in an area you're not an expert in you
just need a little bit of help
yeah you just need to reach out to
someone that knows how to do what you
know how to do
and here at ramsey solutions we know
money that's we are the best at it we
have helped millions
of families get out of debt build wealth
and take control of their future and
that is what we are here to do for you
on the ramsey show triple eight eight
two five five
two two five if you have a question for
anthony o'neil
or myself about money or business you
all know i love to help you with your
business
ideas help you monetize your business
pay yourself stop feeling weird about
selling and all the things that go with
that i would love to help you
or if there's just something in your
life you want to grow as a person you're
questioning you have a question about
your goals
we would love to help you get the advice
that will sell
set you free like i felt yesterday when
i had someone help me
and also go further faster yeah make
more progress you're not supposed to
know how to do it all yourself
you know what it's it's so funny you
talk about you know your session
yesterday i think it was tuesday
it was tues monday or tuesday this week
um i went into my therapy session i
actually see a therapist two times yeah
oh i'm pro
yes yes yes i'm um i see a therapist two
times a month
um and every time i walk in i remember
the first time i walked in there she
said anthony
this is not going to help you if you're
not honest if you're not transparent
if you're not vulnerable and if you're
not open
to the advice and to the wisdom that i'm
going to give you
but i can't give you good advice and
wisdom if you're not giving me the truth
if you're not being vulnerable if you're
not being honest
and and i think for us uh when you give
us a call
you know give us a call because i think
the dumbest question that you can ask
is a no question it's by not asking and
when you call us
we're going to give you practical wisdom
and advice and here's one thing i'll
tell you
and i know it's about christie as well
if we don't know the answer we're going
to tell you
absolutely we don't know the answer
that's right you know i have no problem
seen here saying i don't know bro or i
don't know ma'am i mean
because i don't want to give practical
advice and it's not practical good
advice right
i'm not going to be talking just to be
talking because i do know the weight of
what we carry here at ramsey solutions
and i want to make sure i'm giving you
the right advice and then if it's not
the practical law of advice i'm saying
this this is my personal opinion it's
not law but my personal opinion
um and my therapist is that all the time
christine whenever i leave her office i
remember
we got a bunch of high schoolers in here
and i say in front of them uh i remember
the first time chrissy i walked in
i didn't leave the same i started crying
i was crying like i was a little kid i
was crying like i was younger than them
kids
like that what what was what were those
tears because i opened up
and i never went that deep into saying
you know what
i really want help i mean and i was so
vulnerable and she helped me understand
a lot of the things
that you're going through are not
because of them it's because of
something
deep inside of you that you haven't
resolved
and i was like okay
okay and it felt so good uh to be able
to
have someone to talk to and so if you
give us a call great but if you don't
give us a call
go talk to somebody yeah get practical
help
wisdom from somebody but give us a call
you make a you make a good point about
being honest because sometimes on this
show that's one of the things we have to
do we have to do a little digging
yeah like no no no no tell me the real
story now what's going on there
yeah and and it can be hard to be honest
it can be hard to be vulnerable
but if you're not honest then you can't
do the real work you need to do
to get the help that you need and it
makes me think of this scripture you can
quote me you
know the bible better than i do but no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but painful
however it produces a harvest of
righteousness for those who have been
trained by it
and when we're honest with ourselves
when we reflect on how we contribute to
the problem
maybe weaknesses or blind spots that we
have when we get outside help from
someone that's smarter than us knows
more than us
you and i do that and and that makes us
better people but it also helps you
solve things at the root
issue when you get the help you need
825-5225
we are here for you this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff was diagnosed with heart
disease
it was just such a relief to know that
financial burden
was going to be taken care of chm is the
original and longest serving health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
i'm christy wright hosting with me today
is anthony o'neil and we're taking your
calls about life
money business or whatever you want to
talk about triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna go to
jeff in lexington kentucky hey jeff how
you doing
hi christy doing good uh actually got a
question for you and anthony
uh my first one for you is are you going
to be having a business boutique event
uh this year somewhere in the country
yes we are it's going to be here in
nashville tennessee
and it is going to be in october we are
going to be releasing those dates and
selling tickets soon so thank you for
asking yes we're so excited just
finalizing the speakers
you coming jeff uh
my wife and i are planning on coming
yeah we uh we went two years ago
uh to the one down there in nashville
and that's the first time i'd ever heard
christie speak before
you are amazing and the story that you
tell your testimony that you shared
about your daughter
was amazing thank you thank you well
we'd love to have you i tell you what
you stay on the line and we'll have uh
kelly get you and your wife tickets for
whenever it is released they're not even
released yet so you get the first
tickets jeff there you go
well all right i mean i'm about to call
in too
all right how can anthony and i help
what's your question um anthony my
question i've got for you
uh relates to student loan debt yeah my
wife and i have got some student loan
debt that is in our rears
and we have not gotten like a letter
from a debt collection agency in a
couple years
last time we did of course it's got two
amounts of money only the amount that
was borrowed and the amount
the total amount that has interest and
penalties on there
when yeah when you get to the point in
the baby steps where you're going to pay
this off
will can that amount be negotiated and
if so
to where you only pay what you actually
borrowed and if it can
who do you negotiate that with a debt
collector or do you
do that with the department of the us
department of education how long has it
been in
default man i am not for sure to be
honest with you i honestly don't know
yeah so that really all depends from
there if it's still in the hands of the
federal government
other no they're not going to settle
with you now if they sold it to a
collection agency
um there there's it's a 50 50. it's
really up to them
uh sometimes they will settle uh
sometimes they will not settle
because uh student loans are the hardest
thing
uh to pretty much settle and you can't
even file bankruptcy on them so
my my answer is without knowing all of
the particulars
it depends on who has the student loans
at the time
if it is a collection agency yes a
collection agency you can
settle depending on how far um you are
when it comes to delinquent if you're
only like a year
maybe two years behind and they're just
collecting on behalf of the federal
government uh probably not they may give
you like maybe
you know five percent off uh to settle
it but if you're like five
ten years behind and you're trying to
settle it within one lump sum
um i have seen some some companies go
ahead and do that for you but you just
have to call the collection agency
uh who has your student loans i will
pull your credit report
uh the name will be on there there
should be a number attached to it
and just call them and ask them hey what
are my options to resolve this matter
but the best bet your best way to do
that
jeff is to have a lump sum of cash on
hand
when you get to that part in the baby
step i do not want you to jump there
and skip over your smallest debts if you
still have some
okay all right okay sounds good
all right thank you thanks for calling
appreciate you man
all right we are going to go to bradley
in boston hey bradley how's it going
hi kristin anthony uh thanks for
answering my call yeah um
so recently i got a pretty significant
um
40 raise at work wow congratulations so
yeah it was kind of surprising but i'm
pretty happy with that obviously
um and re financed my fifty thousand
dollars worth of student loans down to
three percent
uh three point seven percent because of
the you know
pretty good refinancing so my question
here is you know should i be
prioritizing the loans or my retirement
because at 3.7 percent
interest that's like it's very small
you know i mean i'm obviously going to
increase how much i'm putting on the
loans but do you think this should be
kind of like a split
um yeah so you have 50 000.
uh yeah on your loan payment how long is
your loan payments man let me ask that
what two years probably i just
refinanced it'll be ten again yeah so
bradley ten perce ten years at three
percent that's a lot of money i don't
know what you mean by saying that that's
that's little of no money
uh three percent over two years like
that well that's how it sounded
what is that something it's something
like uh it should be eleven thousand
dollars okay yeah
i want you to took the whole term yeah
so eleven thousand dollars times that
and invest that into your interest man
you're looking at almost
a half a million dollars that you can
get back just from that eleven thousand
dollars
if it was sitting in investments so even
if you're doing it just for a year bro
any kind of penalty that you're paying
for is not worth it so yes i i when i'm
telling you
how do you bradley uh 23.
yeah bro come on man yes how much how
much is your raise i know you said 40
what's that in dollars uh so that is
uh 84 000 plus and then a commission of
up to 36.
okay okay bradley listen this student
loan's gonna be gone
before you know it if you live right
pretend like you didn't get that raised
bradley
pretend like you didn't get that right
that's what i'm gonna do yeah yeah and
get and get it out of here and then you
can invest all kinds of money
bradley you still living at home no
no on my own okay good yeah do exactly
what chrissy just said man
she she jumped in before i can scream
back sorry so excited so so so she saved
you man you know what i'm saying
this is the problem that i have with
young people it's not you bradley but
it's a problem to have with young people
we're
we're so quick to look at how do we get
the money how do we grow
more money how do we become wealthy
rather than saying hey
how do i create a solid foundation to
build
wealth on okay and so i want you to
knock out all your debt
so this way like chrissy said man when
you're debt free
bro you can go go get the money and
build it and let compound interest work
get into real estate buy your car you
can do whatever you want to do
but i want you to do that on a solid
foundation don't be building wealth and
you owe
people from the past man all right man
get it get out of that yeah
you do it you you're gonna do this
bradley are you gonna do it are you
gonna live like you didn't get this race
yeah i mean i'm i'm not i'm not worried
about it was more of where to put it you
know because it's like
the the retirement is where i'm like
was basically questioning it either way
it's going into savings
i mean it's either going down debt or
going into savings i ain't spending it
on
other things bradley how much money do
you have in savings right now i'm
curious
so that's the thing at my prior
obviously 40 is pretty significant at my
prior
uh it was about 60 000 and due to
it's pretty cost high cost of living in
boston yeah but how much money do you
have
i mean i have a few thousand you know
how much debt do you have
now how much debt do you have total just
that
that's it that's all i own my car i own
everything else cool have you um taken
financial peace university from us
no i haven't i can tell all right i want
you to stay on the line and i want you
to uh
rock out with kelly kelly's going to
connect you with ramsey plus
uh chris and island give that to you for
free for one year i want you to take the
course
uh because um i could tell you're new to
new to the ramsey organization and
that's cool i want you to do that and
you'll see baby steps one through three
so technically right now we only want
you to have a thousand dollars in your
savings account so take that other five
thousand dollars put that towards the
thirty thousand dollars of student loans
you're down to twenty five
and like chrissy said man you should be
debt-free within the next three to six
months if you really work it right
um and so you can be debt-free by the
end of this year building wealth
starting retirement
but i want to walk you through that
process uh and so we're going to give
you a ramsay plus
membership for free you go in there take
financial peace university
and dave um rachel and myself
uh and christy as well and the rest of
our personalities will teach you
how to really set you up to win
financially so you can
retire well because i love the fact that
at 23 years old
and i hope y'all high school is out here
paying attention now looking down at
your cell phones
look at me and chrissy right now okay if
we can get this at a young age get this
financial literacy at a young age
um and really get this wisdom we will be
successful i
promise you uh we will be successful so
take ramsey
plus uh kelly's gonna give that to you
thank you so much for calling in
and uh to the young people listening
right now because you know we
for those who listen on podcasts and um
not really can't really see what's going
on
uh we have a group of high school
students here and i love this christy
because
i wish my teacher would have brought me
to somewhere
like this that's right to get the
education or how to start a business
how to uh grow um you know our finances
the correct way
and so y'all listen to your teacher okay
listen to your teacher cause he gonna
make y'all true millionaires
tv ain't gonna do nothing for y'all all
right hip hop music ain't gonna do
nothing for you just entertain you
listen to that guy that brought you here
andy christie and myself
and we're gonna help you all become
millionaires oh this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright you can follow along
with everything i'm up to on instagram
christy b wright i'm posting today with
my good friend fellow ramsay personality
anthony o'neil and you can also follow
him
on instagram anthony o'neil we love
connecting with you guys all right
anthony we've got a question from
blinds.com
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means that even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use promo code ramsay to get the best
deal
today's question comes from liberty in
oregon
my husband and i just started fbu and we
want to pay off our debt
fast my husband recently asked if i
would be willing to work some hours to
contribute to our efforts
we have one child and are trying for
another before we became parents we
decided i would stay home because having
a full-time parent with our children was
important to us
what's your opinion on family values
versus paying off the debt
quicker now i'm really curious what you
think about this anthony because this is
a values question
and when it comes to values and anthony
and i give you guys advice on values
you're going to get
our values and those may not be the same
so i'm going to
jump no no no no no no no go to you
first go to you okay okay okay good
evening so
one of the things that i actually like
helping people do and i talk about it in
terms of life balance
but i love helping people figure out
what their values are
and then live their life according to
them for example
if you build a business and you look at
other people how they do their
businesses and you structure
the exact same but it doesn't line up
your values you're not going to enjoy
your business because your
business should reflect your values
similarly i
when we we give you guys the baby steps
these are proven principles
but the speed at which you do them and
your stage of life and what you're going
through is going to be customized
for you and your values so
when you say that you want to pay off
your debt fast
liberty and you want to stay home
because that's important to you you're
telling me two things you value and two
things that are important to you
what i would say to you is you need to
decide which is more important
which is more important to you paying
off your debt faster
or staying home with your child in the
season and then picking up the pace
maybe when they're in preschool
i would argue and i'm curious what you
think here ao i would argue there is not
a right or wrong answer here because
it's your values but i will tell you
if you do something that goes against
your values you're going to be
anxious and tense and frustrated if it's
really important to you to stay home in
this season
when you have little teeny kids and
you're maybe have another baby on the
way
and then you go work you're going to
feel a lot of angst and at the same time
if you value paying off that debt faster
then being at home you're going to feel
antsy like hey i need to do something i
need to do something i need to
contribute i need to
and so i i would say you have to decide
which is more important to you and it
may be a blend it may be something
that's why i love helping people start
home-based businesses
because during nap time you could be
making some extra money on etsy and then
you're doing both so there are more
options than you think
but i think it comes down to you
deciding your values what do you think
io
when it comes to speed not the baby
steps because the baby steps are proven
but the speed at which you do it
i think the question should be
asked to the couple what is best for
us moving forward and i think the
inside of that conversation my personal
opinion
we identify okay cool do we want to be
out of debt
so we can enjoy we do we want to be out
of debt
quicker so we can enjoy you being at
home not feeling any pressure
not feeling anything with the kids or do
we mind
having a little bit of pressure while
you're at home
so are you saying the same thing i'm
saying are you no okay of course not
of course not go on go on so what i'm
saying
is for me i'm having the conversation
and i'm trying to respectfully convince
my wife
if i'm in that situation um hey i want
you to go back to work
i do not see that i do really
i feel like in this situation your wife
came to you
and i'm not saying there's a right or
wrong because i'm pro you doing what's
right for you but
if knowing you yeah and how but now wait
i how do i say this i wouldn't be in
this situation
okay so what i'm saying but if i was in
this situation oh okay
i am asking my wife if she's saying hey
i i really want to be out of debt i want
to have freedom and i'm thinking i'm
just thinking as a husband
and as a father you know i want my wife
to raise i want my wife to be at home
and to raise our kids
but i also want us to be at home and
we're not we're not we're not we don't
have any pressure we don't have any
stress
and we know finances can be stressful
yeah and so i would
i would have the conversation now my
wife come and says no i want to stay
home cool beans i'm gonna step up
and i'm gonna do everything i need to do
uh to eliminate the debt so my wife can
so if she said
if she said it's important to me to stay
home yes you would support that
absolutely that's cool that's cool yeah
that you're we're we're tracking we're
on the same page
it's interesting too because when we
talk about um
parenting we talk about working we talk
about women working and how and where
and when they work and what that looks
like this is a
deeply personal issue and so i would
just encourage
every woman listening right now every
family listening right now every parent
listening
it is really important for you and your
spouse to have a conversation
where you are on the same page even if
you have to wrestle through it even if
you have to
go see a counselor to work through it to
be on the same page with this because
you can't look to people around you to
tell you what you should do you don't
need to let your parents tell you what
you should do
your in-laws tell you what you should do
this is your life it's your kids
it's your time and i would say as a mom
of three kids aged six and under
there is a season when they're little
and that season is very
short and goes fast and so um
there are women that stay at home and
think i'm crazy for working outside the
home there are women that work outside
the home that
you know they wish they were homework
there's there's so many different ways
to do it
and you need to decide what's right for
you because this is your life
yeah and that's the only thing that
matters is what is right for you
and your family it's a great question
it's a great discussion ao because
and you see it uh across cultures it
varies
across regions the north versus the
south versus
there's so many different ways to look
at it there's a lot that affects it but
have that conversation with your spouse
about what that looks like for you and
how that affects how you approach the
baby steps
and also let me say this to chrissy
because i want to make sure that we're
saying is saying this in a way to where
everyone hears us correctly
chrissy said it there's no right or
wrong answer here all right
so if you are a couple and you all have
kids and both of you all are working to
pay off debt
that is good for you and your family now
if you're one of the couples and one of
you are saying no i want to go home and
do this and see
chrissy said you should do this anthony
said you should do that don't do that
because at the end of the day you have
to do what's best for you
and your home and as long as you and
your spouse
have a conversation you all agree stick
to that if you want to stay at home mom
and and the husband work or the wife
works doesn't matter that's great for
you
um but just make sure you hear us we're
not saying one is better
than the other well and the thing that i
would add i said this passively but this
is
what i've spent the last six years doing
that's the reason i love helping women
start businesses from home
that's what you have to do but if you
want to during nap time you have a hobby
you want to turn into some income you
have a skill set
education experience degrees you want to
do consulting or freelance work or have
an online business
that's why i started business boutique
that's why i have the business boutique
book and the
and the events and my coaching because
then it gives you a little bit more
options of you're able to contribute
financially if you want to and use your
gifts
but also you get to stay home and work
those hours around
naps and what matters to you the other
thing i would add to this ao before we
head out here is that that this really
applies whether we're talking about
staying home or not
because we get this question on how fast
do i pay off my debt
how gazelle intense i am and you know i
i know people that they have cut out
their cell phone bill their cable bill
they haven't you know
bought anything not anything for and
that's how they get out of debt really
quick and that's cool but i'm going to
be honest when i had my debt free
journey i still had a cell phone
yeah you didn't mean and and i didn't i
didn't go on vacations and stuff but you
decide
the intensity that's right for you yeah
and how much how much you want to go
all in for it because it's your life and
your financial journey
absolutely i saw someone say something
yeah if you're going to get out of debt
you need to
end your gym membership i said if i was
in debt right now i'm not ending my gym
membership
that's just me you have to do what's
best for you you can get gazelle intense
you can get gazelle focus
but your journey may look different from
someone else's journey as long as your
mind is set that i am going to become
debt free
by this time that's the main focus of
what we here at ram
solutions are are really suggesting have
a goal
a goal is specific with a deadline
and do not be lazy with it have a strong
specific time of when you are going to
get out of debt
and you and your spouse or you by
yourself with your single focus and do
everything you need to do
to hit that day that's that date so good
it's a marathon not a sprint
pace yourself for the journey this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here at ramsay solutions we want to
transform so many lives
that disruption spreads like wildfire
across our country
imagine a world where it is weird to
have a student loan
instead of everyone assuming that that's
the only way to get an education
imagine a world where the majority of
people pay cash for their cars
that's weird imagine a world where
credit cards are the cigarette of the
financial industry imagine being a part
of causing that level of disruption with
the work you do
every day at ramsey solutions that's why
we have a thousand people at our company
working together to create digital
products and services to help people
transform their lives
with the goal of disrupting the toxic
money culture that exists in america
today
if you want to join us on that crusade
we are currently on the hunt
for many software engineers with
expertise
in ruby on rails java c-sharp and
front-end technologies i don't know what
any of that means but if you do
you can apply or if you're a ux designer
seo and content marketing specialist
we'd love to talk with you find out
about all the available jobs by texting
work that matters to 33789
that's work that matters all one word to
33789
to find out about all of our open
opportunities
all right we are going to go to james in
miami florida hey james how's it going
uh better than i deserve thank you very
much for taking my call sure how can
anthony and i help
i am well my wife and i are looking to
buy our first home
and my question is should we be as
gazelle intense
and attack the student loan debt first
or save
for a large down payment what's the
situation now give us some some numbers
of the debt and the
so we just paid off a large amount of
debt
when credit cards and the only debt we
have left is her
school loans and
about 335 000.
oh so my my question
you know every youtube channel every
podcast where we're pretty up to date on
all the content so
yep we're just trying to kind of get
some more transparency
on what's her income what's y'all's
income uh james
um so mine fluctuates i i'm
self-employed i own my own company okay
you know salary um but we're let's just
say as an average
about 150 150
000 what's the house situation now are
y'all renting
yes we went okay okay um
james so since you say you're already up
to speed on on our content i think you
already know
what what i'm gonna tell you right um
and it's sad and let me just be real uh
yeah i hate the fact that i can't sit
here and tell you to go get a house
uh it bothers me that i have to sit here
and tell you no i want you to pay off
this 335 000
student loan debt and let's also be real
it's going to take you
some years to pay this off with 150 000
of combined income um uh and here's why
i'm telling you i do not want you to get
a mortgage right now
it's because this debt um
when we did our millionaire study okay
we realized
that they did they have a paid for
mortgage but then number two
they had to pay they paid off all their
student loans
before they even paid off their mortgage
um before they even got in the house to
be honest
and so for me what i want to do is i
want to figure out how can we get this
335
000 knocked out within the next three to
five years
this simply means we gotta get the
income up we need we need to figure out
some way to help
your business to make more profit maybe
chrissy can help us out with that
direction
but then also your wife went to school
and
she i mean with this kind of debt i mean
what kind of law does she do
um she's in like the civil
litigation you know she makes great
money and you know
it's my it's like he's kind of touched
my business fluctuates
yeah what's your business this year so i
own a sign company
okay sorry and um this year
and exactly um the reason why i was able
to kind of knock off or we were able to
knock off the credit card debt was
we do a lot of the political industry
so because and you know this this
scenario may be completely different
in 2024 with the with the new election
but um for 2022 2024 every odd
or every even number is a general in a
primary election so there's going to be
more
volume versus exactly um so
yeah but james i got to jump in here
your business is not based on every two
years
right like your signed company is not
based on politics because that's not a
good business model so
who's your other target customers what
is how long have you had your business
who else do you sell to market to
it can't just be wait wait until the
next election
five years i've been in business five
years and you know if it's not political
then we focus on commercial okay
business to business call um you know we
exactly we do retail signs you know all
signs
printing advertising all that arena cool
okay
so what is your business generating a
year like what are you profiting because
at 150 are you saying your wife is doing
about 75
and you're doing like the other 75 or is
it more like 100 and
during your off years you're bringing in
like 50. like what's what's the
breakdown here i would say
yeah i may have um shorted myself a
little bit it's anywhere from like 50 to
75
okay depending on you know last two
years ago it was it was right around
there 75
okay net net so you know like a 150
girls something like that
okay and your wife is doing about the
same you said
yeah she's at you know and you know her
industry
faces you know bonus and and things of
that nature and i don't want to kind of
get too detailed but yeah
you know her her salary is is a little
bit different than mine
because she's got you know a solid
employer and they do bonuses and
you know there's always room for uh
ranges
yeah well there's room for races but you
control your business i mean
you you have you have a lot more levers
to pull
and it's not a perfect formula of like
there's buttons you need to push and
you're just not pushing it i know it's
not that simple in business but i will
just encourage you
that because you and your wife make a
good income
it would hypothetically james be
easy to get a little comfortable and not
have that fire under you
and i want you to get a fire under you
yeah i want you bringing in over a
hundred thousand
i want you getting this business up and
going you're in a good business it's a
proven business it can get there
it might just be look at you uh
maximizing what you've been doing in the
past that has worked for you and trying
some new things
and if things are if the industry is
down because it's a year after politics
or because of covet or because of
whatever people aren't buying it you
know
you got to figure out what's what's
going on
but it might be time to pivot or try
something new or try something online or
try a different
stream of revenue but we're not just i
just don't want you to sit tight
and just wait till the next election i
don't want you to accept that this is
the most your business can do
i want you to set some really aggressive
goals in your business revenue
and in your personal income because
because you own your own business
you can do that yeah and and i just want
to encourage you there if you will stay
on the line james
we will have uh kelly send you a copy of
entre leadership
great business book by dave ramsey is
our playbook of how he built
this business from a card table in his
living room and i'll tell you james
regardless of what's going on the market
what you need is what
i hope you have and that's tenacity
perseverance
persistence and just a will not take no
for an answer
attitude where you are rethinking the
business and looking for ways to get new
business and looking for ways to get new
streams of revenue uh i want to hear
that in your voice and then when you do
that you get that income up
you'll be able to attack this debt that
we're talking about so much faster yeah
i
mean
and here's here's the truth i mean if we
look at the numbers you've got 150 in
debt you're making 150 you're saying
three three something dollars 350 i'm
sorry yeah 150
of income i'm thinking if you really do
this math well
here okay you're looking at about maybe
five years
you and your wife can honestly be out of
debt if you really aggressively go after
it i know that seems like a long time
but man the average person it takes them
anywhere between 12 to 20 years
they pay off their student loans that
are right around 38 000
and so with the 150 income what i'm
saying is figure out how do we spend
50 grand a month okay to go towards
the student loan debt and then if you
get your income up like christy said
you mean a year you said 50 grand a
month that feels very good
that's very aggressive thank you christy
but 50 grand a year
uh man you'll be out of debt here very
real quick in five years or five years
man i've been here for six
and i feel like it's only been like two
years uh so i'm telling you right now
man
you can do it the business the business
is your key to get there
i'm telling you james you have got you
got an ace in your pocket
you got to turn the dial up on that one
that's going to be your ticket to get
there
i want to thank producer james childs
and associate producer kelly daniel and
my co-host anthony o'neil
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is kelly associate
producer for the ramsay show
did you know that over 16 million people
listen to the ramsey show every week
and a lot of those people listed on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
daveramsey.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright your
host today
along with me today is anthony o'neil
you can find both of us on instagram at
christybeewright
and at anthony o'neil we are both author
speakers and
ramsay personalities and we are here for
you so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
we can answer your questions about money
about business
about life whatever you wanna talk about
we are here
for you all right let's go to the phones
we've got cindy in los
angeles hey cindy how's it going good
how about you christy
good how can anthony and i help hi my
question is
when is the right time to invent
all right take it away ao that's a good
question cindy um
why do you ask a question i'm curious
where are you at in your financial
journey
an intervening i paid out my paid off my
student loans
last year and um right now i'm trying to
pay off my car
um i've got myself gave myself a
deadline on may 22nd
okay that's good you was listening into
the phone calls that's great
how much debt do you have left outside
of a mortgage so what's your consumer
debt looking like the total
um actually i don't have a mortgage i
was wanting to get a home but i figured
that paying off my car was the first
goal
absolutely um i'm a travel nurse so i'm
like i'm just paying off my day i don't
have
um right now i'm just staying with
family with my traveling career
okay it's awesome how much is on your
car right now then
um thirty thirty thousand thirty k what
kind of car you driving cindy
infinity you're driving an infinity that
must be like a 20 25 huh
oh man you bothered just you know you
lived and you learned and i had so many
cars and you know just building i'm like
no i just want to get out of bed
i feel you i feel you hey so i know
traveling nurses make real good money
especially on the road because you don't
have to pay taxes on your uh travel
expenses and stuff like that so what
would you say you make
what's your weekly right now um that
you're making a week uh
weekly it would be um like 3 500. so
you're making 12
000 a month after taxes because you pay
minimum tax when you're traveling you're
doing about about 8 500 what's what
you're seeing a month
right yeah right um so here's the thing
um i want you to pay off the car okay uh
i don't want you doing the investing
because it all depends on what company
you're with when it comes to travel
nurses inc so i don't want you to pick
one particular company
uh because you may switch uh with
different assignments so i would
definitely say just going ahead
pay off the car get very aggressive with
that if you're living with family
you should be able to have this car paid
off within three months all right
i want to get very very aggressive with
that then after that
um do you do you only travel and use one
company to find an
assignment uh for your traveling nursing
or do you use multiple companies to help
you find different assignments
um one company cool so do they offer a
401k
all they do i actually looked at the
401k last
night okay cool is it is it a roth
ira and do they match and they do match
perfect so as soon as you get done from
there i want you to just put three
months
three months aside into an um to a
savings account because it'll be easy
for you to get a job in a nursing field
so once you get done within the next
three months paying off the car then i
what i want you to do is go ahead and
just set aside three months of your
average expenses
um so just look and just gauge as far as
then if you're gonna do an airbnb when
you're traveling
what do you need to live for three
months and i'm thinking for you maybe 10
15 grand
then from there then that's when i want
you to start investing
and go ahead and use the uh 401k roth
and so when it comes to investing
roth first okay roth beaches a match
beats a match matt beast beats some sand
beach uh
beast i know i want to go to the beach
and then a match beats uh
a traditional so roth first trade i mean
match next then a traditional all right
but right now
do the first two things first pay off
your car get a fully funded emergency
fund then start investing so
great question cindy yeah thanks for
calling i love travel in nursing anthony
you know a lot about it first of all
that's impressive
you know that you know the deal the
lingo all that hey real quick for for
everyone listening right now do a quick
recap on why we tell people
to pay off your debt before you invest
because we get this question all the
time yeah
and it's a major hang up where people
feel oh i'm leaving money on the table
my employer offers this that and the
other talk a little bit about this
focused intensity of one thing at a time
and why the baby steps work the way that
they do i think it's a good reminder for
people
absolutely you know i i'll come from my
personal story you know when i
was focused on just one thing paying off
my debt
and baby step uh number two um lining up
all your debt from smallest to largest
using the debt snowball method
i was able to focus solely on that
studies show chrissy that when you are
in debt and you're also trying to invest
you only invest about one to two percent
so it's not really a lot of money right
so if you could keep that one or two
percent put that on top of your debt
and just get very focused with that
you're going to get out of debt
quicker then we teach you're going to
set aside an emergency fund to present
to prevent you from going back into debt
so this way when you start investing
15 of your income you're not worried
about going
backwards what we're trying to do is
keep people going
forward the problem that we see in the
world today is that they'll pay a little
bit of debt
uh they go over here invest a little bit
then they'll get back into a whole bunch
more debt then they'll come back over
here and start investing a little bit
then what they'll do is take out of
their investment
to go pay off their loans and that's not
what we want you to do we want you to
focus on one thing
create a solid foundation for you to
build on then you're going to create a
layer on top of that foundation which is
which is an emergency fund
then from there we're going to create
some revenue to invest into our future
so that way
when we do retire we can retire with
peace and with joy and with freedom and
enjoy
our retirement um and so that's one
thing
why we really really teach that
foundation it's because we want you to
have something
strong to stand on not something rocky i
think people underestimate the power of
focus
and just focusing on one thing at a time
they think i'm going to do all these
things simultaneously
and when you try to do a million things
simultaneously you feel scattered
because you
are and so you don't feel like you're
making any progress do you know that
research shows that the most motivating
thing
for human beings it doesn't matter your
personality style the most motivating
thing
is not rewards or pay raise or even
words of affirmation or recognition
the most motivating thing is seeing
progress
absolutely when you see progress you
want to make more progress if you eat
salads for a week and you don't see the
scale go down you want to go back to
eating cookies and pizza
but if you see the scale go down you get
more what else can i do i'm going to
drink more water i'm going to work out
again
seeing progress whether it's with a
weight loss goal with a business goal
with your
debt snowball when you see progress it
propels you forward
to make more progress so that's the
reason we love to help you all
have focus on one thing at a time when
you focus on one thing at a time you see
progress there which propels you forward
you know one of the things i see with
women starting businesses
anthony with the part of the downside of
having such ease to start a business is
women start like 15.
side businesses and i'm like what do you
do they're like i do hair and walk dogs
and i do landscaping and i have a
boutique and i make hair bows and i'm
also accounting and on the weekends i
make barbecue
yeah it's almost like i don't know what
you do it's almost like our newest
personality john deloney i know if y'all
know who he is
he he's scattered all over the place he
wants to be strong he wants to be fit he
wants to be
this and i'm like i'm like john just
focus on one
thing bro just focus on one
thing and he's in the studio we're just
giving him a hard time giving him
because we have the microphone today
that's right oh my gosh it's good focus
creates momentum creates more progress
yes
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
i'm chrissy wright hanging out with me
today is anthony o'neil and we're taking
your calls
about life business and of course as
always money give us a call triple eight
eight two
five five two two five we're gonna go to
the phones we've got mason
in louisville hey mason how's it going
uh how are you all good what's your
question question for anthony or
myself okay well i'm 19 years old and
i'm currently on a gap year
pursuing uh kind of my dreams
through my business and also working
throughout high school and
you know working multiple jobs and um i
was
wondering i have about 20 000 of that
invested
between mutual funds individual stocks
and
sneakers that's my business but i was
wondering what i should do without the
other 20
000 all right you're cutting out a
little bit can you give me those numbers
again in the very beginning you said
you've got how much money
that you got from where uh sorry a
little over forty thousand offers
okay forty thousand dollars and twenty
of that is invested in
individual stocks mutual funds and
sneakers
because that's my little business that i
run
well it's not little mason it's not
little it doesn't sound like it is to me
let's just cut out the word little and
then tell me tell me a little bit more
about your situation you're in a gap
year
what do you have any debt what else is
going on
i do not have any debt um yes i'm on a
gap year and
right now my thinker business has gone
to uh
depth that it has never been before
because it's currently my full-time job
and
yeah how many years have you had this
business
i actually started in sixth grade and
every year it became
more increasingly um you know i became
more invested in it wow that's so sixth
grade
that's crazy that's awesome hey man
you're sharp bro yeah let me let me just
be real
you you sharp i mean you you really
appreciate that
all right so let me help you out with
the language here and chrissy can maybe
even help me
with this as well when you say invested
um
that's money that you have invested with
getting a return on as far as in like
interest now your sneaker business is
not an investment
you know that's that's your business
unless there's something we're missing
here
yeah yeah so it's like well a lot of
these things i consider
this is because most of them over time
appreciate
value some of what's going on for a year
maybe two years
and some of them even go up five ten
dollars a week
so not consider those to you as
investors but they're technically not
really
there yeah yeah so let's say you you
have a sneaker business
and then let's say you have other funds
invested
um into mutual funds into single stocks
all right
and then the business part i totally get
i mean because all if you're in business
you're in it to make profit and so i
totally understand
your perspective on that part um
at your age uh just to make sure i heard
you correctly because you're going in
you are going in and out you're in a gap
year of college are you going back to
college number one and number two
how are you paying for college are you
using scholarships grants
are you cash flowing what are you doing
or are you taking out student loans
well i do plan on going back to college
i kind of use this year also to figure
out what i wanted to go into and i've
narrowed it down a little bit more but i
still haven't decided completely okay
i will be attending a community college
my local community college
and i haven't decided if i'll be staying
at home with my family or if i'll be
renting an apartment with somebody
and are we taking out student loans or
how are you how are you paying for it
um definitely some scholarships but
there probably will be some student
loans
okay but i think every year probably
four thousand there so i'm probably
paying it off with one a job as well
yeah so
there's no point of paying it off when
you have forty thousand dollars in cash
right now
so for me i'm going to cash out those
single stocks
and i'm gonna put that on top of the
twenty thousand dollars that you have
left
cash liquid and then i'm just going to
pay for the rest of my college
up front cash okay
um i'm cool with you keeping keeping
some of it inside your mutual fund
because
if it's only going to cost you four
grand to go to a community college you
really need a grant
and then from there we need to figure
out what are you going to do for the
next two years are you going to an
in-state school
asking that because that's going to run
you in kentucky yeah right at about
eight to ten thousand dollars
if you go to in in state schools so that
20 granted you have right there
i hear it in your voice i hear it you
know you're you're you're a young man
trying to make some money you know
trying trying to get this back real
quick and i understand it
but but what i want you to do is set
yourself up to win
long term okay and the average
person says this mason that hey i'm
going to pay it off within two to three
years
after i graduate that same average
person takes them 12 years to pay it off
okay and so what i'm saying is if you
already have the funds
up front here's the best investment you
can make that's into yourself
yes at 19 years old investing into your
i wish you could see me on youtube
because i'm pointing at my brain
investing into this right here that's
your greatest asset
not sneakers not the stock market
not anything else you are your greatest
asset
if you can get this mind all the wisdom
and knowledge that it needs to be
productive on the business side
man man stocks can't compete with you
you know sneakers can't compete with you
so what i'm going to say is
to go cash out your single stocks pull
that stuff out bro
and pay cash for college if you do that
bruh your sneaker business gonna it's
gonna take off that's that's the thing
that people have to keep in mind anthony
is it's not either or
you're you're you're making an
investment in both this you are doing
awesome in the sneaker business
because of just grit and tenacity and
scrappiness
and you're a go-getter that started in
the sixth grade which is crazy and
awesome
you get some actual business principles
and education and training and strategy
you're gonna be challenged to look at
your business in a new way
and it's going to it's going to open up
tons of doors of growth and opportunity
because you got that outside perspective
it's like
we kicked off this morning talking about
or this afternoon talking about
getting outside advice from people that
are experts in their space or no more
than you
it's going to help you take it to that
next level where you're not just winging
it the whole time you actually got a
little bit different layer of
sophistication
in running your business and at some
point if you want to scale mason you
want to grow a team you're going to need
to know how to be a leader
and all that good stuff so that will
help you do that i love love that advice
all right let's go to emma in chicago
hey emma how's it going
good how are you good what's your
question for anthony now
um so my husband and i we have started
this journey of
going debt free very early on in 2020
right before the pandemic hits
unfortunately uh during that time i lost
my job
and then after that we work on my second
baby
so we use part of our saving
to pay some of our debt like mostly
credit cards
and right now we are to the point where
uh
we do not have the six months
you know savings and i just feel like we
should stop
um because we stopped opening a bed
until
i get a job and of course my husband
he's not on board with me he really want
to just keep going
i mean we have been blessed that you
know um
we're able to live comfortably with one
salary
and even able to save that thousand
dollars every month but i
just feel like i you know we should stop
right there
yeah until i get a job and then continue
on with our you know our goals real
quick emma because we're about to go to
break how much debt do you have left
together
real quick okay so student student loans
is
is the highest um that we're not even
gonna tackle that right now
but what's your total how much 220
000 220k okay cool and how much is your
husband making right now in this job
um he makes it 140. 140 000
yes oh yeah you all need to stop that
yeah don't don't stop no
keep going emma um and then and then on
the on the um on the uh the credit cards
uh
i think we have about 8000 left yeah
yeah yeah that that's cool
i mean 140 000 income uh you guys um
renting or do you have a mortgage
payment we do have a mortgage we have a
condo how much is your mortgage payment
uh right now everything all together is
about uh 1700.
okay cool yeah uh so here's my thing
emma you guys are making good income
com the average combined household in
america today
is at 58 000 and so you all are not just
double y'all are double plus some uh so
you don't need to pause nothing
what y'all need to do is get on the
clear budget and see how do you all
continue moving forward with you
uh losing your income but hey don't
pause keep going
y'all got a lot to do okay
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a recent survey said that over 64
percent of americans
changed their spending habits in 2020
plan to have a pandemic proof budget
that you can pro that can protect you
from another year of impulse buying and
spending more than you make
reset your money habits by getting the
ramsay proven
and easy to use cash management systems
the starter envelope system for a very
limited time you can get our famous
starter envelope system for only
five dollars if you're constantly going
overboard in a certain category maybe
your food or closed budget then take
cash out for the amount you've budgeted
for
and stick it in an envelope when you
shop for that category
only use what's in the envelope once the
money is gone
it's gone so you can't overspend how
easy
is that the starter envelope system will
help you manage your money and keep your
budget in check
plus we are marking it down to only five
dollars to help you get back on track
pick one up for yourself family and
friends while they are 72
off visit us at daveramsey.com
backslash store today that's a deal
anthony yeah listen
yeah i'm going to buy me a few of those
tonight five dollars i got some members
who uh family members who go over their
their budget all the time so i've been
reading my kids the juniors books
junior's adventures book and there's the
one about um you know junior the
careless at the carnival and he's got
his little envelopes and he goes and he
spends all the money on all the games
and
then doesn't have any money for the
tilt-a-whirl or whatever it is and
it's funny because i feel like my son's
getting it and then we went to target
the other day because he wanted to buy
something and he had his little envelope
they got he picked out something that
was more than that was in his little
envelope yeah
and i said well that's you don't have
enough money for that right and he said
well well let's just like i just i just
want to get it anyway i said right but
see that envelope
you don't have enough money for that and
he goes where's your purse i go no no no
no no
no no no no no he goes your purse is
right there what about in your wallet
what's in your wallet i was like nothing
for you
nothing for you all right we are going
to giovanni
in new york new york hey giovanni how's
it going
hey guys it's going good great to be on
the show what's up a.l just found your
show recently too at the table
some really good stuff thank you bro
awesome what's going on no
no problem so my wife and i just got
married in january congrats
before getting married thank you i
appreciate it before getting married i
had no debt
and about 11 000 which served as my
emergency fund
after marriage my wife and i had like
the serious conversation about our
finances
and we realized that my wife had about
forty four thousand dollars in debt
okay um we started the program and we're
down to thirty nine thousand so we've
paid about five down
together so far i know following your
principles we should throw the ten
thousand states straight at the debt
however i'm wondering if i should still
do that even though i'm in the process
of transitioning between jobs
i'm currently joining the new york city
fire department i'm going to be in the
academy between may and september
so i'm wondering if i should keep that
11 000 as a cushion for now until i
graduate from the academy and i have
some job security
uh good good question man number one
yeah congrats on marriage bro
um and thank you appreciate it i love
that but uh
let's talk here what does your wife do
for a living
so she works with children in um group
homes
uh she has a psychology degree so she
actually in the future wants a further
education and open up
uh her own clinic what's her income
so together her and i both we bring home
uh well she brings home 3200 a month and
i'm bringing home about three a month
okay so 3 200 a month and you bring home
about three so i bring my sixty two
hundred dollars a month but then you're
about to transition and go down to
thirty two hundred dollars
a month correct um
are you gonna be making money while
you're at the academy yes i'll be making
around the same rom in the academy
i guess it's just the pressure of
potentially like
failing out which i don't want to think
about obviously but yeah
there's always that option that's
there's there's always what ifs giovanni
there's always what ifs
could the sky fall i mean you know like
there's always what ifs but we don't
make decisions
yeah based on fear the fact that you've
got that stable income
you're good to go and in fact i think
that if you kept that cushion you might
even get a little bit more comfortable
yep uh yeah hey ao take it away i know
no chrissy i mean you're hitting right
on the money man i'm taking that ten
thousand dollars bro and i'm putting it
on there
that's going to leave me at 29k if you
all are making
6 200 a month what's your mortgage
payment right now or your rent payment
yeah our mortgage is uh 14.61 but we
also pay
hoa i'm trying to do a quick math in my
head it comes out about 1640.
okay so about 1640 and is this 6200
is that gross or is that net um that's
that's big home that's net okay so so
you guys are still bringing in 5k
yeah man you could be debt free in the
next uh five to six months if you are
really attacking and work that budget i
would definitely get on every dollar
uh i will go over to ramsayplus.com
right now uh download
the every dollar app get on a very
straight but budget giovanni
and just figure out okay how do we work
the debt snowball now
um i agree with christy i don't want you
to get too
comfortable at all but if you want to
take it maybe just a notch down a little
bit
while you're in transition i'm okay with
that because you two are young
you're already putting ten thousand
dollars towards it leaves you with 29k
you're still bringing in sixty two
hundred dollars right after that you're
looking at about fifty what's that forty
eight hundred bucks
that you have left i would really put
about a good
three grand towards his debt uh and get
really aggressive with it
while you're in school that leaves you
with a cushion of about a grand to go
ahead and play around and pay some
utility bills
some food stuff like that but right now
i don't want y'all being too comfortable
bro
i want you to attack this while you're
young while you have the resources to do
it because you do not know what the
future holds
and i would rather you get your new job
get your good career
your 100 debt free and get your three to
six months of your savings back into
your account
then you start investing into your
future so those are my two cents bro but
congrats on the marriage and
i'm excited about y'all's future yeah
and i would say stay on the line let's
have
kelly give you a membership you and your
wife to ramsay plus where you can get on
a budget that like we're talking about
you can watch
the lessons uh go through financial
peace university that's going to set
your marriage off on the right track
financially i want to point out
something anthony yeah that
i see a lot of times in these types of
calls uh
and i'm not saying you're doing this
giovanni except i'm saying you might be
doing this giovanni
so she's saying you're doing it here's
here's what i see here's what i say it's
just a maybe
i'm just gonna throw this out there when
you have two people get married
and one of them has been very
financially responsible and they're very
proud of the fact that they are
debt-free and have eleven thousand
dollars in savings yes
and you have someone else coming to
marriage and they've got some debt the
person that has been responsible before
marriage
sometimes has a hard time letting go of
that money that's good because
it's a source of pride look what i did
i've been responsible
and now in an instant it's going to all
of a sudden all that hard work window
but here's the thing
when you put a ring on it it's y'all's
money it's y'all's debt
it's y'all's goals it's y'all y'all i'm
a tennessee girl i'm gonna say it 500
times
together this is your money your debt
your goals and your futures so while i
think what he's saying is valid about
the concerns about transition i would
say there may be a little bit of
something else going on below the
surface of like
oh but i worked so hard to save this
eleven thousand you mean i just gotta
heard that you know
and that's that's that's a thing so can
i play the devil's advocate here yeah
let's have it
keyword here america play okay
too late they've already torn you up i
want to play devil's advocate so
let's say i am the man and i get married
and she does have you know thirty
thousand dollars in debt and i got forty
thousand dollars i've been saving up
you know to go towards my mortgage
payment you trying to tell me i'm
supposed to give that up because i got
married and she didn't have her
you know her her business in place yes
finances in place yes
so all my hard work over the last five
years yes i give it up
a thousand because my wife
wasn't financially good when i met her
if you're not ready to be a team don't
get married
and let me tell you i will be super
transparent right here i will be super
transparent
this was matt and i story i got who had
the money
matt and you had the debt i like man no
no listen no no
let me let me finish i paid off my debt
are you ready for this
okay paid off my last debt my last car
payment
one week before he proposed he had had
the ring had planned the date to propose
already he already had this plan he we
didn't talk to finances
until we got engaged for real so he
didn't know i mean he knew i was paying
off my dad like that way
i was transparent i i became debt-free
we had a uh uh was a we went hiking and
we had that like hiking date planned
yeah and he proposed the place that we
had met where we'd run in
trail running and i want you know when
we got married which is a lesson for you
america what a good man i had when we
got married
and he had a a great savings account
been a responsible debt free
did not have any questions about how we
paid for that wedding matt wright paid
for that wedding
and he said that tears coming down my
face and he said
no he said it's our money oh he never
never held it over my head never said
you should have done whatever
be that kind of man it's our money i
like matt
be a good man like matt wright i'm
dancing for matt right now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright you can find me on
instagram christiebright and hanging out
with me today is anthony o'neil
at anthony o'neil on instagram we are
answering your questions about life
money business or whatever you want to
talk about triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're gonna
go to
jennifer in harrisburg pennsylvania hey
jennifer how's it going
hey guys how are you good how can
anthony and i help
well i have a what would dave do
question
okay so well and here's the situation i
recently got my master's in social work
and after two years i finally got a job
in my field using my degree um
and i just was given an option today
currently
i do nine months where i work night i
work in schools
nine months a year and then i have the
three months off in the summer
um and at i was 37 000 and 11
is what i would make um i just found out
that if i were to work 12 months out of
the year
i could make 48 49
000 a year so there's a 12 000
difference just by working an extra
three months
now the commute time would still be the
same i'm still commuting about two hours
a day total
the caveat in here is the key is i'm a
single mom
and have been um all my life well all of
my son's life i have you know and so
it's like i'm kind of torn do i
work the nine months and have the
summer's office done with him
and just really try to pay off the debt
with the lower income
or do i take the other uh the higher
income
and sacrifice time with my son how how
um how much debt do you have
um seventy thousand held yourself on
student loans
i'm his time and what time do you get
off work in the
um on the school day or summer day like
what's your schedule like
it varies um if i'm working in the
schools i can be done when the schools
are done and then at the hour to meet
home
so i began like 2 30 so i'd be home like
3 30.
um if i'm not working in the schools if
i'm working at the office
i'm getting done at four o'clock and not
getting home until five o'clock 5 30
depending on traffic
yeah i'm gonna this is another one we
were talking about this earlier today
which is why i'm asking a lot of
questions because this is a super
personal issue but i'm gonna tell you
what i would do
i would absolutely do it you're talking
about a massive increase
in income short-term sacrifice long-term
reward
and i will being transparent here my mom
was a single mom and she took me to her
cake shop with her
i i mean i spent more time at the cake
shop you know with with her employees
than i did my friends a lot of my
childhood
and i turned out fine and and i and i
i'm not the only person but i just i
just want to encourage single moms out
there
don't be sorry for the struggle you're
you're not harming your kids by the
struggle by being a team saying we're
going to sacrifice together this is what
we do this is how life is we're in it
together we're
we're a team your kids aren't gonna make
it uh despite the struggle they're gonna
make it because of it i am who i am
because of what mom and i went through
together and so i just
i think that you have uh you have so
much potential to get out of debt so
much faster
with these three months in the summer a
few years that you can make so much more
progress so i would say i lean heavily
towards
yes take that extra income work those
hours and you're not talking about
you're getting off at seven o'clock at
night you don't see them you still
have an opportunity to see him so but
again it's i have to be very cautious
when i'm telling women what you should
do
with your children that is super
personal jennifer and so i want you to
hold all this loosely as this is another
woman to woman saying this is what i
would do but i'm not you and it's not my
child
and that's a very uh personal decision
but i think that that
the sacrifice you're talking about a few
months in the summer for the long-term
payoff of getting out of debt so much
faster and that much income in a short
amount of time
in my opinion is absolutely worth it
that's me ayo so i'm gonna echo what
chrissy said and i'm gonna break it down
from a financial perspective
okay um i think number one i'm gonna
have a conversation with my
my children say hey this is what mother
is doing and this is
why mother is doing it uh so that way
they know you're not just doing
something just because and they're not
feeling a certain kind of way they
understand why mom is doing it
now on the flip side when we break down
the math okay
if you're getting an extra 12 000 um a
year that's an extra 1 000
a month and if you're 70 000
in debt if you can put 15 000
a year towards his debt it will take you
right about four years to get out of
this
uh about four years and some change to
get out of this and i think that's a
great
sacrifice and if you tell your kids hey
the next few years
mother is doing this so i can set myself
up
to be a better mother a better provider
for you all
long term so when you go off to college
we can make sure that you do not have to
do what i did
so mom is going to do this for the next
uh four years so we could do this but
here's the thing
um jennifer you have to be very
strategic these next four years that's
fifteen thousand dollars a year if you
can get on your budget and figure out
how you can squeeze out another
thousand dollars in that year you can
cut that down to about three and a half
years so
i'm with christy i'm going to echo that
i think that
it doesn't and i want to say this as
well too it doesn't make you a bad
mother because you're not there
as much as you would like as long as you
are communicating with your
your children as long as you're
communicating with your family the
reason
why prime example my mom uh worked three
jobs christy when we were growing up
three jobs she worked for the school
district in the morning times uh then
after that she go work for kmart when
kmart was around and after that she'll
work for the christian bookstore on the
weekends
and she did that and she told us why you
know why she did that between
september all the way up until december
the week before christmas
she said hey your mom's not going to be
around a lot right now because i want to
make sure that you all have a good
christmas
and so mom's going to get off work and
go work another job and every time my
mom went to work
we got excited because we was like wow
mom is doing that for us
so how you explain it and communicate to
your kids
what's going on and make them feel like
it's going to benefit them in the long
run
your kids should i'm not going to say oh
because some of us are crazy
um uh they should be like mama i i get
you mama i love you
mama thank you so much uh but i think
from the practical side
if you work the math in your benefit
if you put the extra 1 000 a month all
towards your debt the latest you could
be out of debt is in four years and two
months
if you could squeeze out another
thousand dollars you could be out of
debt within a matter of about three and
a half years
yeah and the the one thing i would add
jennifer is i would say that if you
decide to go this route that anthony and
i
are recommending i would say don't feel
like a victim to it
choose it say oh yeah i'm doing this for
us i'm all in
and say i get to do this i get to still
get off at 2
30 or whatever time you said there are
some people that uh you know they work
three
jobs for several years they don't see
their kids at all because it's it's a
it's that
sacrifice for a major debt or medical
school i remember meg meeker
uh anthony told me she did you know
there was literally years like a couple
years when she didn't see her kids
hardly at all
because it was a long-term goal of being
a doctor and that type of thing but
i would just look for all the good in
this of oh my gosh you still get to see
your kids you still get to see him
him or your son in the afternoons you
get to spend time with him you get to uh
still go to the park be outside it's not
like you don't get to see them at all
yeah but let's be real too though
chrissy how many people have to work
every single month they don't get two or
three months right right that's what i
mean
it feels like a lot to you but it's
still such a blessing if you choose to
look at it that way
of yes this is more than i'm used to but
i can do this
here's the blessings that are still
camped in this if i get off at this time
and this is what normal people work and
all that type of thing
and then it will change your attitude
when you drive to work in the summer
yeah because i don't want you driving to
work in the summer jennifer
with a scowl on your face and you're
disgruntled if i don't want to be doing
this and you feel like a victim
you're not a victim you're choosing this
yeah i'm choosing
if you do i'm choosing to work these
extra months to get out of debt quicker
for my son and i long term to be free
and then you can have all the summers
you want to
the the other thing that i would say is
remember it's a season anthony just gave
you a timeline three and a half to four
years
this is the season it's not forever yeah
i had a similar conversation with my
family
uh anthony in the spring of 2017 when i
was about to launch my book business
boutique
i was like now mommy's about to be on
the road matt and i talked about we've
talked with the family talk to everybody
what is this going to look like what's
going to look like i'm not here a lot
and it's going to look like i'm going to
need a lot of help
in the grand scheme of things this is a
small amount of time
for this goal this calling that i have
to get the book out there
this doesn't mean forever when you
realize it's a season
then it gives you the strength to get
through it that's good it's not forever
it's just we're going to buckle down for
this period of time whatever that period
of time is
we're going to buckle down for this
period of time to get through it yup
i want to thank producer james child and
associate producer kelly daniel
and my co-host anthony o'neil and you
america
for listening in this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm an
author
speaker and ramsey personality and i'm
joined today by my good friend
also an author speaker and ramsay
personality
anthony o'neal and we are taking your
calls give us call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you have a question about money
life or business and anthony i love it
when we get to host together because we
get excited yeah we go back and forth
and
one of the things i like about hosting
with you is we'll take these calls and
take some questions
and then unpack the answer absolutely
and and really dig into it a little bit
deeper
and that's a lot of fun all right let's
go to the phones we've got angela
in salt lake city hey angela how's it
going
good how are you good what's your
question today
so my husband and i are currently
knocking out our debt
and most of our debt is coming from our
two vehicles
and we both decided that we're going to
sell them this spring because we got
some equity in them
the problem that i've got is my husband
um wants to use some of that equity to
purchase
a used dirt bike for the summer um
and i know that it wouldn't have a loan
on it
um technically we would still own our
vehicles outright cause we'd be down
downgrading but i just wanted to see
what your input is on that and if that's
a smart move or if it's a bad idea i
know that he
really um his heart set on it and i've
already
gotten him to agree with selling his
beloved truck so
i just kind of want to know what what i
can
i can do yeah is your husband there with
you angela
no he's working anthony wants to show
directly to him angela could you give us
a call back i'm just kidding
man she's sneaking it in while he's
going i know she's like oh he's gone oh
let me just get some outside input here
i
love this and i know christie's going to
have my best
christie's going to have my best i
actually have your back right now i'm so
ready for this
uh well hey listen so let me let me make
sure i understand this correctly
uh once you all sell your two cars
you're gonna be out of debt you'll have
cash cards correct
yes okay cool how much money will you
have in your savings account well you
had a three to six
the three to six months in your savings
account
no we um have we currently have the 1000
in our emergency fund then yeah
um i i hate to say this without your
husband being there because i want him
thinking we're talking behind his back
but you're right i mean
we shouldn't be purchasing anything
major like that we need to
lay down a solid foundation and to
prevent you all from going back into
debt you need a fully funded emergency
fund
so once you always combine household
income right now angela
about 95 000. okay so 95 thousand
dollars
what's your mortgage payment um
total with our hoa it's about 1600
okay so 1600 so right now you need about
10 grand in your savings account to get
the three to three months of your
expenses i would say
i'm curious so um
initially he thought that he could get
one around three thousand but it seems
like the prices things are going up and
it's looking more like forty five
hundred dollars
yeah four to five hundred dollars
so four thousand five hundred dollars
yeah the kind of estimate he gave me
okay yeah yeah so that's half of your
your three to six months so
so no no so no uh
you know what angela i gotta tell you i
when you said he has his heart set on it
like i i get that man i get my heart set
on things too the thing is
is we just have to be grown-ups and we
have to do things in the right order
and it doesn't mean he can't get the
dirt bite ever bike ever
it just means we're not going to get it
when we don't even have more than a
thousand dollars in our bank account
right does that make sense yeah that
makes sense yeah
so just just encourage him in that sense
when you break the news to him of this
news that anthony and i have given you
when he's been out of the house please
tell him it doesn't mean not ever
it just means not right now that's our
that's our advice for you
and here's a rule of thumb that i go by
uh christie for me okay
and this is not really something that
ramsay teaches it's just something that
i've been teaching
since i've come uh up underneath ramsey
and teaching something
i don't really buy something like that
unless i can afford it at least twice
okay so it's like for me when i purchase
my my used car
um if you follow me you know what i
purchased i won't say here on the radio
i didn't purchase it though until i had
at least
twice that amount in my account here's
why let's say he goes and buy the dirt
bike can he has the 5 000
cash and then he comes back home what
happens
he has no money he's broke so if an
emergency happens
no he doesn't have any money so for me
my philosophy is
on top of my emergency fund can i afford
to purchase this twice
if that's a gucci purse if that's a car
if that's a backpack if that's a kitchen
remodel i remember you gave that example
a couple weeks ago when you and i hosted
together someone called in with a
kitchen remodel and they had like the
exact amount
of money and no cushion and i remember
you saying that same thing yeah yeah you
want you want to have some cushioning
because you don't know what will happen
especially on the kitchen remodel you
remember that like if the estimate is 20
000 oh you're going to spend about 25 to
30 000 on the car well and that
when that example with the kitchen yeah
you don't know how much something's
going to cost but even with the dirt
bike i mean
i hope nothing ever happens but that's a
very dangerous sport is it a sport yeah
it is
i don't know how the hobby whatever
that's that can be really dangerous
and i would hate for anything to happen
a record you have to go to the hospital
anything like that with something so
risky and you got a thousand dollars in
your pickup absolutely yeah yeah so i
mean
that's why i say just make sure you can
afford to buy it twice i got that from
jay-z for those of y'all asking where i
got it from
i love it all right let's go to austin
in philadelphia hey austin what's going
on
hello rachel hello anthony how's it
going hi it's christy i am christy
but i love rachel and that's a
compliment no problem no problem i'll
take it
yes rachel and ayo are here for you
what's up mel awesome
i tried i tried um so basically i'm i
just turned 23.
i'm pretty financially secure i
definitely can't complain with that
um i stress about money a lot more than
the average person
well maybe not but um and i just i
i don't know about my career i know i
don't want to do it for much longer
i don't know why not what do you do
transition and i do highway construction
okay and like when you say financially
secure what's your savings your debt
free
yeah i uh owe 18 000 on my car
and i got about between my real estate
and
other savings i have about half a
million
what you have five hundred thousand
dollars in your account
and three investments about
give or take about three hundred
thousand and um
how much do you have like mutual funds
and stuff like that cool high rates 401k
okay cool how much you have liquid in
your savings account right now
i have a a little over a hundred
thousand
or over 100 000. okay cool great and i
also own a house cash
okay cool great um uh because we're
about to go to break bro i'm gonna help
you out real quick
um you are secure okay you need to take
that money out and pay off your car
okay why do you have a house debt free
but you still
you know have eighteen thousand dollars
on your card so i'll go ahead and pay
that off
in regards to the career perspective or
side of things not perspective but to
the career side of things
i would encourage you it sounds like
you're not happy um i would encourage
you to uh
check out our good friend ken coleman
who's our career expert
i would call into his show on monday um
and tell him hey
i'm great financially just paid off my
car chrissy and anthony told me do that
on friday
can you help me find or figure out how
to land my sweet spot into a career that
i actually
love uh he would help you out with that
so give him a call
monday or tuesday of next week and he'll
walk you through that but hey
young man you're killing the game this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright co-hosting with me
today is anthony o'neil
we are good friends we are ramsay
personalities and we are here for you
answering your calls about money life
business life balance tough situation
you're in you're not sure which decision
to make and you just want an outside
person
to give you a new perspective we are
here for you
all right we're gonna go to the phones
we've got nikki in richmond virginia
hey nikki how's it going hi how are
y'all doing today
good how can anthony and i help good
thank you
so much for taking my call i do
appreciate it
um so um we're debt free we actually are
in baby steps seven we was there
um to the station in december under our
debt free
screen congratulations thank you thank
you
so we do have a question now um so
our household income is around 138 140
000
a year based pay and um so
what we're calling for is um we're
living in
a home now that my husband purchased
when um he was single
um and during that time um when our
debt-free journey we wanted to go ahead
and include the mortgage because it was
like only only
like 52 um thousand dollars on it so
that's how we became debt-free
the home is older it was built in 1956
and we've been living here
um and we intended not to live here
forever um but we had a plan to purchase
our together home
and so we were going to stay here for
two or three years to save up um for the
house because we were thinking the value
was like 120
000. but we had an eop to come out on
yesterday
and since it's the seller market he told
us what the comp price was and now the
value is 165 000.
so with our initial plan was to stay in
the home for two or three years to save
to do the one thousand i mean a hundred
percent down
um but given it's a seller market should
we sell now
and take approximately 150 000 and
then go into apartment for a year and a
half to two years until we have enough
400
down or do we continue to stay in the
home that we're in
um for another two to three years and
then sell
but i guess my only fear is will it
still be a seller market
at that time yeah that's that's a great
question you know i sold my house as
well when it was a seller's mark and i'm
telling you right now
your house will not be on the market for
long i mean i sold my house within a
matter of like
20 not even not even 30 minutes i mean
the house
received offers so i think right now
it's up to you you and your family i
mean do you
if i was in your shoes yes i'm putting a
house on the market today
um and then i'm gonna go rent something
real small um
uh just so we can stay low on our
expenses
so we can save up more money and then
when when it becomes a
buyer's market uh then i'm going to go
out there because i do believe
it's a mountain you're going to have a
seller's market buyers market sellers
market buyers market
and so as soon as the buyers market
comes back around
absolutely you should be able to go out
there and find something great
yeah great question and the one thing i
would add to this is uh
for those of you guys that are calling
in with real estate questions that type
of thing anthony and i
are always as are always the the ramsey
personalities
uh we're talking with each other and
we're talking with our elps we're
talking with dave ramsey himself say hey
we got a call we weren't sure about this
and this is one of those questions that
uh we have heard directly from dave that
this is what he would recommend to do
which is interesting to me because the
the nature of the market we're in right
now is so unique yeah
and it's one of those things where it's
like oh what is the right thing to do
and so
um so yeah that that uh that's something
we've been talking about here
and uh congratulations nick you've done
a great job to build a solid foundation
uh this is not a step back for you it's
a strategic step forward it's just a
little looks a little bit
different than maybe what you had in
mind but great question
all right we have got a question from
andrew in l.a hey andrew how's it going
oh it's going pretty well and just
wanted to say that
you christy and ayo you're a dream team
and i'm hoping that you guys co-host
morocco
they help each other really well hey man
she gets me in trouble sometimes
but you know you get yourself in trouble
i just highlight it
i believe that hey hold up bro really
what's your question andrew what's your
question
so my job is mobile and i can do it from
pretty much anywhere in the world
and my wife wants to be a writer for
kids animation in 2019 she landed her
dream job working on a popular
children's show
and we moved to los angeles and in the
pandemic hit
and there were a lot of changes in her
company she was let go and they're not
going to be bringing her back when
things lift up
she's been trying her hardest to network
grow her online following talk to the
right people improve her skills
she's often working like 60 hours a week
to do that
and she's landed a few freelance gigs
but all of them are short-term and none
of them
require her to live in los angeles it's
been over a year and living in the city
has been really draining on both my
emotions and our finances
and i want her to attract to achieve her
dream but it's really hard to justify
living in such an expensive area when
we're getting little to no benefit from
being here
yeah at what point should we throw in
the towel and move to a less expensive
area
probably out of state or should we just
double down on pursuing her dream for as
long as we can
i think i think whenever we've talked
about this before uh anthony but
whenever i feel like it's these extreme
examples it's this or this and they both
feel really extreme and they both feel
really bad i felt start to feel a little
anxious
and i would say it doesn't have to be
that i would say that should you move
out of california i would if i were you
you've been there a year you've given it
a shot and the job she's getting she
doesn't have to be there
does that mean you can never come back
no does it mean she can't do her dream
job somewhere else no
i mean i just would take the pressure
off of like you have to make your
lifelong decision
based on right now which is a weird
couple years a weird market job market
real estate market all of that i would
just say if you don't have to be there
right now and
i mean i'm assuming you and your wife
have talked about this but that she's
okay
with moving too yeah i would if i were
you i would get those those jobs that
don't require you to be in california
save a lot of money have a lot of fun
see a new area
have options and then if in a different
year a different time a different season
you look at your options and you want to
go back because there's something that
only happens there
then you can but the the reason that
you're there is no longer there anymore
yeah and so when things change things
need to change so i i would i would i
would head out yeah
i think i'm almost there with you too as
well chrissy andrew what's y'all's
household income right now
um she brought in around 30 000 last
year from her freelance gigs
and i brought in about um
net probably about 150 000. 150
and uh she brought in 30 000 net as well
um probably gross so probably closer to
like
20 000 that because again taxes are
really high here
okay so 170k yeah man i'm i'm leaving
i'm leaving california with that
i mean now 170 is still not bad income
you know
um it goes quick in l.a though it goes
real quick in la yeah it really
it moves fast in california period
california
new york um so if i'm if i'm you again
me personally i'm looking at places like
tennessee like texas
uh somewhere to where i can get
something nice be very comfortable
um somewhere that has like a lot of land
and i can you know buy some things so
i would definitely leave man i i would
be having that conversation with my wife
uh tonight in san bay by this summer i
think it's time to leave
now here's the thing don't forget just
like our last call you're in a seller's
market so i wouldn't be trying to buy
anything
right now i would move somewhere
rent something for the rest of the the
rest of this year stack up some bread
um uh um and then let me answer this
question and you might have said this so
i'm sorry if i'm repeating but do you
have any debt right
now uh just a mortgage on a rental
property
that uh we were living in and then when
we moved here for the job we kept it
and we're paying that off it's worth we
bought it at
5 45 and we've paid it down to about 112
right now
okay cool great and then you have how
much money do you have liquid to you
right now
cash in the savings uh liquid um
let's see i have a roughly
oh gosh after i make my step ira
contribution it'll be around
40 000 ish in our emergency fund and
then
i have a non-retirement and school fund
that has about
90 000 in it yeah some move yeah i'm
saying move
i mean looking to look into some of
these states and see where y'all want to
go
and that's and the reason why i say
texas is because it's a
it's a 45 minute flight back to la if
something was to come up
with her dreams down the road i just
want to i just want to point out one
thing andrew you are a really supportive
husband
yeah the fact that y'all moved there for
her dream job you're staying for her
dream job
you're considering staying longer for
her dream job she's bringing in 30
000 a year with this dream that's like
it's we're trying to get it going and
you are
still believing in her that is an
awesome
husband well done for believing in her
yeah i'm just
i'm really i'm really impressed by that
so regardless of where you end up
she's got a good husband that believes
in her and y'all are gonna be just fine
you're doing great financially
and you're gonna be just fine well done
mentor some of us other brothers with
that same love brother
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
well are you tired of feeling stuck with
your money like you'll never get out of
debt or
save enough for the future listen it
doesn't have to be that way
you can make progress with your money
and faster than you think
but the only way to make it happen is
with a budget
that's why you need a ramsey plus
membership you'll get access to the
premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app
where you will first plan out every
dollar that you'll spend and
save before the month begins also
connect your budget to your bank so you
never miss a transaction
and even get custom reports that show
you where you can find more money to put
towards your goals
when you budget and actually get
intentional with your money you will
make progress
fast and you can start budgeting for
free today
to start your free trial of ramsay plus
go to daveramsey.com
that's daveramsey.com
right let's go to derek in albuquerque
new mexico hey derek how's it going
good how about yourself good what's your
question for anthony and i
so i have a question about investment uh
my wife and i have a little bit of extra
pocket cash
that i've held on to for quite some time
and i want to know what would be the
best investment to put
my my money in i have about eight
thousand dollars uh
that i have in pocket cash and i would
like to you know have it make some money
i do currently have
a 401k with my job that i have right now
and i know that eight thousand dollars
ain't much but we do have
the thousand dollars for the emergency
funds we have the three months in the
bank
and everything else so i just want to
put it somewhere instead of underneath
my bed
i like that man now hey just want to
make sure i'm clear
you have no consumer debt no student
loans no credit cards
none of this correct no sir i worked my
tail off to
to pay it all off um get everything paid
off the only thing that we do have
right now is a mortgage okay yeah we
just bought our first house
so walk me through baby step four where
we're investing
15 how much are you investing in your
401k right now
well that's where it kind of gets a
little tricky because
i'm the only in source of income right
now okay and i did knock it down to the
matching with which they match me five
percent
okay and i'm putting in five percent
right now okay uh my wife is a
stay-at-home mom
and she's gonna be working here in the
next six to eight months something like
that
okay are you investing into a roth ira
or any mutual no
i am not all right cool so that's where
you're gonna put this extra eight
thousand dollars because again
uh we want you to invest 15
of the household income so right now
you're only investing five
percent so what we need to do is take
this other eight thousand dollars and
put
that inside of an investment but then
also moving forward
every month you're gonna be matching
your your uh five percent which
401k they're gonna take some more money
and you're gonna put that inside of
a roth ira so i would definitely jump on
the line with one of our smart vested
pros have them walk you through this
whole process
because you may depending on your income
you may not be able you you'll max out
your roth ira but then you may have some
extra money left over from there as well
from with your 15 percent
so we may come back to your 401k dump
some stuff into that or
if you have hsa with your job you could
just dump some of that money into your
hsa
but right now i think the key thing is
the very first thing is you need to go
uh max out to your your roth iras uh
jump on the line with one of our
smartbest pros go to daveramsey.com type
in smart bester
and uh you'll get phone calls from about
five to six of our smart messer pros
and and here's the thing derek um
interview all of a man
because what i hear in him christy is
that he's very passionate
he's trying to do the right thing and so
when it comes to
investors and financial advisors sit
down and find the best fit for
you and your wife and someone that can
teach you along this
along your journey here uh so great
question man
love it um love your heart uh
congratulations on being debt free and
yeah
i love it when someone has extra cash
and they're like where can i invest it
not what can i buy so you're you're
gonna do great
well done all right we've got taylor in
south bend indiana hey taylor how's it
going
hey it's going thank you yeah what's
your question
um well i'm just working on just the
next step
um i'm i'll be 27 this year i go
26. you're cutting out on us taylor
you're 26 you have a girlfriend that's
26
i'm trying to piece it together here my
girl
i'm sorry we were fortunate enough to
buy a house in december before this
crazy spring market
i have no debt she has probably
um yeah sorry sorry taylor we cannot
hear you maybe call back when you've got
a little bit better connection let's
move on to
nathan in des moines where's let's see
here there we go
nathan how are you oh i'm good thank you
so much for having me on guys
yeah how can anthony and i help so this
is a relationship
question sort of just in general terms
since i'm in my
second year in college i was kind of
putting my nose to the grindstone for
like my first two years doing like 18
credit hours
and i was gonna drop that for my junior
senior year once
the coursework becomes heavier but i
just wanted to know how much should i
like put towards like my social life
since i sort of felt left out on some
things
so like what would you guys say like how
much should i like try to put towards
the social life
i'm curious uh about the why behind that
is are you trying to graduate early
are you what's the reason for go getting
such a large course load
so it was mostly because my my father is
like one of the big influences in my
life he's like
he said like to always push to do the
best you can and i was like
you're right because he's paying pretty
much through my way through college so i
gotta like
make sure that i impress my parents you
know i can't
hurt the piggy bank so yeah
yeah yeah well let me ask you this
question you are
you're young man um and i feel like
you're you're feeling like man i'm
missing out on fun i'm missing out on
life
but are you really missing out on life
because you're working hard and you're
using your youthfulness
uh wisely right now
i i i don't know i i because it's like
everyone tells about how like college is
this experience
and then i feel like the parties and
stuff happen and you always get that
like sort of feeling like i kind of wish
i was there
yeah let me hold on hold on let me let
me help you out here brother we're going
we gonna we gonna park right here
we're gonna park right here because
i just want to say this right cause i'm
not on i'm not at the table so i can't
say
you know certain things on the ramsay
show uh but here here here's what you're
not seeing
you're seeing parties but you're also
could be seen because i'm going to say
everyone who parties uh
they are not uh good students they're
not making a's but
what i don't want you to do is is look
at the fun
life look at uh the exterior life and
see kids partying
you're seeing kids having boyfriends and
girlfriends you're seeing your peers
having fun you do not know what's on the
flip side of their choices today
okay what you need to do is be focused
on solely your
life have a ton of vision hey i am
focusing today
i am getting an education today i am
taking these extra classes today
i am working hard today i am making the
right choice for my life today
so that the caliber of my future is
better
tomorrow okay so yes are you gonna be a
little uncomfortable today
will you miss out on a little bit of
things today yes you will but let me
tell you this much man the average
person is going to work until they're 75
80 years old you're not going to be
average because you're going to make the
right decisions today
you're going to retire at 45 you may
become a millionaire at 35.
i don't know the way you signing right
now you may be rich before you even can
blink you know what i'm saying
so you got to focus on your life don't
focus on their life
you focus on your life give your life
all the attention
and i promise you down the road you'll
thank yourself for not worrying about
what they were doing because
they could be in debt they will be
working until they're 80 years old
they will be driving uber at 90 years
old trying to get some money but
you will be in a wise position man so
don't worry about that
stuff you get fired up yeah when i hear
young people i want to dig into this
though when we come back from the break
i want to dig into this because i think
you have a really great point
and i have some questions about it so
this is no this is good
this is good because it's a valid
question whether it's about your college
or even
someone working in a job working lots of
hours i want to dig into this because
this is an important conversation
okay this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scripture of the day for the word of the
lord
is right and true he is faithful in all
he does
that's psalm 33 4 and jack canfield said
for every reason
it's not possible there are hundreds of
people who have faced
the same circumstances and succeeded
that's a good word i like that no
excuses no excuses
okay anthony before we went to break uh
we had a call college student
working his tail off 18 hour course load
missing out on friendships
my question for you that i wanted to ask
and we ran out of time my question for
you is
when is enough and i mean this literally
so so you could always work more you
could always take more classes you
do more more more and more to make more
progress faster at one point do you go
i'm i am pushing the limits i'm working
really hard i'm being a good steward of
my time
my course load my work whatever that
thing is for you because this isn't just
a college student question you could
apply this to work i could get six extra
jobs
at what point is it enough and you go
yeah i'm not gonna
um i don't want it to be this black hole
like it's never enough it's never enough
and you don't get to enjoy your life now
i don't want him going to parties but to
have friendships or have hobbies or have
time off
at what point because you you for the
longest time worked with teens and
college students i know you still do
at what point do you say like hey you're
doing a great job
you can have you can go on a picnic
something you know
virtuous on the weekends whatever
where it's not a bad thing to have a
life i'm curious
no i and chrissy i actually learned this
from you you know you you teach
priorities
you know uh and i think for me once you
set your priorities in life
just make sure that those priorities are
being accomplished so if education is
your number one priority right now
then i think that you need to be focused
on that and what does that
what what what do you have to do to
accomplish that
now do you need to be taking you know 10
classes a semester no
i mean but can you take some extra
classes this semester
right absolutely right um but if after
prior
after education uh relationships healthy
relationships are important to you
then yes you know you make time to build
healthy relationships
uh but for me i think i i tend to focus
on
one thing and one thing only probably
one of the main reasons why
i'm not married yet because i was
focused on transitioning into this new
career that i had
yeah and so i really wanted to focus
solely on
just you know um learning ramsey's uh
culture learning everything we teach and
talk about when it comes to finances and
i was in i was studying i was learning
everything about dave learning
everything about our team
now i'm in the seasons where i'm i'm
ready for a relationship that's actually
my number one priority
uh right now so i'm focused on that and
other things fall behind that so i think
once you just outline your priorities
then you're able to really gauge from
okay what am i doing too much
what am i actually not doing enough of
yeah it's interesting that's a really
good point because i've noticed in my
life and especially working with
different personality types and people
different strengths and weaknesses
i feel like that at least for me in my
faith
god is always stretching me where i'm
weak so i tell people you know if you're
that type a go-getter workaholic you
have a bent towards being a workaholic
you have a bent towards
you know at all costs you might need to
learn to take a
sabbath you might need to learn to make
a friend yeah
but for the person that they're doing
the bare minimum yeah they're taking
hardly any classes they're just skating
by you need to
give it some gusto you need to work hard
so it's almost like we all kind of
tend to swing to these extremes and i
think the growth happens
when you grow in areas that you're weak
yeah when you figure out what is that
what is hard for me
and let me do that so even just i was
curious with him because that's one of
those things like he sounds like that
go-getter
that's like he is a perfectionist he's
hard work which is awesome
but at the same time maybe there's some
growth there all right great uh great
conversation all right we're going to go
to
ferris in houston texas hey ferris how's
it going
good how are y'all doing here good
what's your question for anthony not
today
uh so i and i just recently graduated uh
2019 december and i have about
20 000 in a student loan debt that has
been deferred i haven't had to pay
one payment yet and
i recently in october i bought a car
um i make about 55
a year pre-tax 55 and
55 yeah um and the reason why i bought a
car is that because i got 72 months
interest free
and my car payment is only about 280 a
month
i was wondering um how if i should sell
my car now
man i hate hearing now i got 72 months
interest free zero interest you're still
in that
it's not free money ferris you're still
in debt yeah you're still in that fair
what kind of car did you buy uh a toyota
camry sxc
you bought a toyota camry what a toyota
camry it's an xrc how much was it
how much did you pay for it uh i put
down
nine thousand down payment um i have
about twenty thousand left on it
okay so your total debt is forty
thousand
yes right now my total debt is about 40
000. so let me get this straight
before you got the car you had 20 000
in debt and you had 9 000
cash uh yeah and i also have about
17 or eighteen thousand dollars in the
stock market
okay ferris i'm gonna calm down bro
walking through the baby steps walking
through the baby we'll walk you through
the baby steps ferris and then i want
you to i i i need to interview you on my
show because i think a lot of young
people will love
your story all right so far here here's
what i'm going to recommend man
here's what your income right now is 55
000
a year you owe 20 000 left in the car
all right so here's what i want you to
do
right now you need to put all you need
to stop everything you're doing and you
need to go
um i'm going to give you a free year
of ramsay plus okay so stay on the line
when we get off kelly's going to give
that to you and i want you to watch all
the classes
okay because i don't have enough time to
walk you through all the baby steps
but babysit number one is a thousand
dollars in your emergency fund the
number two is you're gonna pay off
all of your debt using the debt snowball
the reason why i'm kind of like if
you're watching me on youtube you see my
facial expressions and my hands going
all over the place and i know the
producers bryce and anthony calm down
and and chrissy is like oh my lord
anthony's getting upset is because i'm
hearing a young man
you could have been debt-free bro you
could have been 100 debt-free and you
could have paid cash
for the car you're you're the young man
that i wish i could have got a hold of
you
you know three months ago before you
purchased the car uh because i would
have said all right cool let's get you a
car
you got 17 000 in single stocks right
now right
um and then you have say it again
it's all an apple it's all in apple yeah
so 17 000
in single stocks you had 9 000
in um in cash so you're sitting at 28
000 what yes yeah about 28 about 27 000
right there uh so i'm like man listen um
let's pay off to 20 000
in debt and then let's take the rest of
that go buy a cash card for right now
and then from there let's start working
our way up
to go ahead and get you into the toyota
camry into something a little bit more
nicer that you really want it
but right now we can't do that so
um i want you to go ahead and focus on
paying off
uh this 20 thousand dollars in in
student loans you're gonna line your
debt
up from smallest to largest and you have
two options okay
um and i'm gonna treat you just like how
dave was here you have two options
you can sell the car which i would do in
your situation
um or because it is only worth it's less
than half of your your actual income
um you can just get very aggressive with
it and pay that car off
um but if you go that route man i'm
talking about you need to go out there
and get you an extra job it's a nice car
you need to be driving for uber you need
to be delivering pizza
i want to see you debt free within the
next six months
bottom line okay okay and so um you can
sell your card
uh that would be great the the the
problem that you're gonna have from
there is
will you have the cash to go buy you a
used car that's the problem
so you're saying hey anthony i can sell
the car and get the cash to go buy a new
car
i'm going that route if you're saying
anthony i can bust my butt within the
next six months to pay off all of my
debt
i'm cool with that too yeah the the
thing to remember too
as well ferris is it it's not free money
yeah don't make this a mistake again
when you get debt free like anthony told
you just
the next time someone says oh zero
percent interest for however long it
does not matter you're still in debt
it is still buying something you cannot
afford
and when you do that you are taking
steps backwards not steps forward
in america no it's not free it was just
it inside of your car
okay that's it
anthony this is good this is fun today
we get fired up i love hanging out with
you i want to thank producer james
childs associate producer kelly daniel
my co-host anthony o'neil and you
america for hanging out with us this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you